industrializar indústrias lá em uma
palavra que no seu conceito nos remete
praticamente o início da civilização
humana pois industrializar significa
acima de tudo transformar modificar e o
ser humano já há milênios efetua
transformação e modificação de matéria
prima os objetos de desejo mas somente
no século 19
com o advento da primeira revolução
industrial a industrialização como se
concebia até antes mudou
consideravelmente
aquele processo aparentemente artesanal
e se transformar as matérias primas
aquele que tinha à sua disposição nem
outras áreas
entendeu-se e com um objecto de fornecer
não apenas com a sua subsistência mas
também para negociar com outros com
outras sociedades outros países uma
metodologia nova de uma manufatura maior
com mais implementação requerido e
requererem tomava requerida e tomava
tempo naquele momento da mente da
primeira revolução industrial ocorrida
em meados do século 19 na inglaterra
seguiu se uma segunda revolução
industrial de forma aparentemente mais
complexa mas que se expandia não apenas
para países do ocidente europeu mas
também para outros países
antigamente colônias como estados unidos
países asiáticos principalmente japão e
américa do sul também diante disso aí
segundos cada vez mais nesse novo
processo de industrialização a
necessidade de implementação de sistemas
fabris cada vez mais complexos mas
baseado acima de tudo a necessidade de
fornecimento ea sociedade
então na época considerava como
necessário para aproveitar melhor com
mais conforto ea custos mais acessíveis
aquele sistema que ali se encontrava
podemos dizer que a segunda revolução
industrial até os momentos de hoje com
esse última fase que podemos colocar
como sendo a terceira fase da revolução
industrial
nós conhecemos o homem contemporâneo
fortemente afetado e com uma convivência
muito próxima com o conceito de
industrialização
o ex passado praticamente 200 anos que a
concepção de uma indústria moderna
passou a fazer parte da sociedade
o mundo e o homem como conhecemos
antes na primeira revolução industrial
ele não apenas mudou consideravelmente
mas ele deixou uma marca que com a
presença do sistema industrial não mais
retornar ia ser como era antes
a percepção da influência na indústria
nas sociedades
ela se fez de forma não apenas
irreversível mas se nós pensarmos bem à
indústria ele passou a afetar
diretamente não apenas os produtos que
consumimos e que venham das suas
profissões
mas ela passou a afetar de forma direta
a maneira como vivemos ea sociedade como
mesmo concebemos hoje em dia
para gente tem uma percepção da
importância da indústria na nossa vida
não é difícil fazermos o correlato de
forma muito rápida
se nós imaginarmos o nosso dia a dia
se pegarmos por exemplo um simples dia
na nossa vida
observamos que desde o momento em que
nós acordamos desde o momento que nós
acordamos na cama que dormimos no
colchão que ali está que vem da
indústria a partir do momento que
adentramos nos primeiros momentos do
nosso dia todo os processo todos os
produtos que encontramos nos ambientes
na nossa casa são produtos
industrializados
o transporte que utilizamos para vir a
pecar seja ele o veículo de massa seja
ele um veículo próprio uma bicicleta
também produtos industrializados até
mesmo nas rodovias que aqui nós hoje
dispomos passa por processo
industrializados e aqui chegando o nosso
redor praticamente tudo que nos cerca
hoje depende diretamente de
industrialização mais do que se a
perceber a importância do produto
é importante a gente te ver o que isso
significa
pões quando a gente observa que o
produto como conseqüência é obra de um
tratamento muito superior do que ele
próprio
se vocês observarem no decorrer nos
últimos 200 anos
a evolução da sociedade foi determinada
por tivesse processo mas a
industrialização nesta evolução ela
contribuiu e contribui hoje de forma
irreversível
para se ter uma idéia os números
mundiais diretamente ligados à indústria
nos passa que aproximadamente 82 por
cento de toda a mão de obra técnica
hoje que em atividade está passando por
um estudo de qualificação diretamente
está conectado a uma necessidade
industrial uma necessidade de
continuidade da revolução industrial o
brasil ele de forma alguma ele passou
desapercebido nesse processo uma breve
história da indústria no brasil que teve
na época de getúlio seguida com
juscelino kubischek e foi introduzido na
década de 70 e 80 a industrialização
chegou uma forma mais globalizada no
brasil e fortemente nos anos 80 no
brasil também observou se o índice de
qualificação ea melhoria na qualificação
também das ofertas educacionais
fortemente a partir dos anos 70 quando a
demanda dessa mão de obra por
qualificação maior cresceu enormemente a
participação da indústria na economia
mundial e brasileira
ela determina fortemente o nível de
desenvolvimento de uma sociedade e do
seu povo
no decorrer dos anos 70 e 80 com o
advento da indústria no brasil
nós tivemos o índice de participação que
era superior a 30 por cento do pib
brasileiro
no decorrer dos anos 80 essa
participação se manteve praticamente
estável e no decorrer dos anos 90
nós observamos particularmente no brasil
e tem ocorrido breves cenas na
participação do crime num setor
industrial brasileiro
mas o mais importante desse processo que
determina o quanto é importante a
contínua evolução de uma sociedade com
sua conexão com a indústria faz com a
observação dos índices que aceite
claramente observa
tanto no brasil quanto nos principais
países em desenvolvimento
daí sortimentos se faz necessário que a
gente observe o que é importante para
que essa participação da
industrialização no país
mais particularmente no brasil possa ser
fortalecido com medidas que assegure que
nos próximos anos a gente possa é
incontestavelmente o fortalecimento
desta indústria no estudo muito recente
apresentado pela ceni foram apontados
cinco fatores
eles são considerados determinantes para
que o setor industrial brasileiro se
mantenha não apenas forte mas que ele
evolua e não perca essa participação no
pib brasileiro
esses fatores eles afetam a economia
como um todo
mas esse grau de importância desses
fatores tem uma correlação intensa não
apenas uma indústria mais com as
próprias universidades eo incremento do
pib do brasil
ele consta hoje com 25% vindo na
indústria mas a sua reprodução ele afeta
outros setores podendo ter esse
percentual multiplicado até 52 por cento
da economia com a influência direta e
indireta
nesse estudo da cnm foi identificado
esses cinco principais fatores primeiro
fator que veio a ser fortemente
trabalhado o efeito da alta carga
tributária ou seja dos impostos que se
paga observá da mente
há pouco mais de 20 anos atrás quando a
indústria brasileira participava com
quase 30 por cento do pib nacional
a carga tributária ela não chegava a 26
por cento dos produtos industrializados
atualmente com a participação de 25 por
cento do pib nacional
a carga tributária ela chega hoje a
atingir aproximadamente 41 por cento de
todos os cursos na industrialização de
um produto no brasil
o segundo fator é uma demanda interna e
suficiente isso diretamente está ligado
a uma baixa movimentação da economia
mais nitidamente nos últimos quatro
trimestres
naturalmente é importante que se note
que o primeiro setor uma baixa demanda
que é afetado e que reagem mais
rapidamente é o setor industrial a
partir do momento que os índices começam
a demonstrar uma tendência de redução no
processo econômico de um país
a indústria a primeira dá os seus amigos
ea primeira a fazer os seus ajustes
necessariamente a manutenção da demanda
ou a promoção de uma demanda mais
pujante é fundamental para que a
indústria continue fortalecido no
decorrer dos próximos meses
falta o alto custo da energia para que
se tenha uma idéia o custo de energia e
no processo industrial ele varinha e
movimentos
dependendo da manufatura e no seco
industrial a que se refere
nós podemos ter alguns setores onde a
demanda por energia com a participação
do seu custo ela não chega a ultrapassar
3% outros
por outro lado chega no ombro fatura de
alguns produtos a exemplo de manufatura
cinema música que a minha
somente o curso
energia para movimentação e
transformação daquele outro produto pode
atingir até 56% seu uso
imagine então uma desestruturação no
gosto do fornecimento de energia do
brasil toma aqui ultimamente a gente tem
participado de energia por si só ela
encarece enormemente o custo do produto
a falta de energia ou uma energia de
forma inconstante ela pior mais ainda a
possibilidade de uma estabilidade
industrial taxa de câmbio
alguns têm entendimento do universo
quando a gente percebe e você gol de
trabalho com moedas nossa moeda não leva
é conhecida no mercado internacional mas
o dólar ou eu ou são as moedas
habitualmente utilizados para a própria
ea taxa de câmbio nos afeta diretamente
tanto como importador exportador
poderia se dizer que enquanto exportador
isso seria uma benesse muito grande para
o brasil ea ue os produtos aqui
manufaturados
no entanto é bom é importante se
demonstre que boa parte da produção
interna de produtos manufaturados no
brasil dependem directamente fortemente
e todos os setores industriais tanto nos
manufaturados tanto na agricultura tanto
quanto na construção e diversos outros
segmentos da indústria de produtos
diretamente constituídos ou produzidos
fora do brasil e como nós vivemos numa
economia globalizada
boa parte desses produtos não são
marcados com mais um real mas sim como
moedas mais fortes como nova é tão
obrigatoriamente somos fortemente
afetado seu povo a partir do momento que
sofremos rápido
são campeão e que afetará os cursos
tanto para o mercado interno quanto
também para sermos competitivo a nível
de exportação e taxas de juros elevadas
essas mudanças bruscas como acontece com
os outros setores
elas se agrava mais ainda quando nós
feitos quando nós temos que nos deparar
o financiamento de processos industriais
aquilo que foi o principal motivador e é
até hoje o principal motivador de
qualquer implementação industrial é o
capital sem o capital a um custo
competitivo você não pode implementar
nem no início nem a continuidade de um
processo industrial muito erros a
manufatura desses produtos a um custo
competitivo para que se tenha uma idéia
atualmente o brasil ele compete em
eventos em diversos segmentos com países
que hoje têm uma taxa de juro anual que
varia de ponto 3 por cento a 2 contra 1
por cento ao ano
para citar um exemplo como estados
unidos que hoje você consegue fazer
captações que variam em média de 1.80 um
ano ou no mercado chinês que hoje você
consegue fazer captações por roubo de
2.1 cento
e se você tiver um acesso você pode ir
ao mercado japonês fazer a captação
pagando 10.1 cento ao ano
diante disso aí observa se claramente
que a manutenção de uma política de taxa
de juros elevaram longo prazo ela
prejudica não apenas o processo
industrial
mas toda expectativa de uma
implementação de longo prazo desde que o
processo é importante que é um esporro
esses cinco elementos que foi tão
comprovadamente é colocado pela cna e
seus mais de 2 mil entrevistados como os
industriais
a indústria para o desenvolvimento de um
país ela é indispensável não somente
para o empreendedor e e tendo como
decorrência a produção de produtos para
o seu mercado interno e escreve mas é
importante que se observa que a história
tem se provado que dentro em todos os
grandes países desenvolvidos do mundo
a indústria foi sim a base do seu
desenvolvimento moderno
a concepção do ser humano o homem
contemporâneo
ela só foi possível com os últimos 150
anos
a partir do processo do desenvolvimento
do processo industrial
diante disso o z aprimoração uma melhor
educação
ela passa diretamente pelo
engrandecimento de um processo
industrial motivado protegido e assim de
todo compartilhado como uma política de
uma sociedade
obrigado